Good evening
everybody. My name my name is Bil and
I'm so glad for meeting you Miss Dr.
Zach. Actually I have a
question. My first question
is what is the meaning of religion and
why do we follow religion? Is there any
different between religion?
Fister asked a question that what is the
meaning of religion and which religion
should we follow correct? Yes. Very good
question. Tomorrow my talk is on this
topic. Tomorrow yes I'm giving a talk on
this topic. Religion in the right
perspective but since you ask I'll just
say in brief. For more details come
tomorrow. Okay. Religion according to
Oxford dictionary means a belief in a
superhuman controlling power a personal
god or gods that deserve worship. So
religion basically means to believe and
worship one god. So if you can
understand the concept of god in the
religion you'll understand that religion
correctly. Which religion is the best?
The same question brother asked. Allah
says in the Quran in Surah Imran 3 verse
number 19 in Islam the only religion the
only way of life acceptable in the sight
of God is Islam. Islam means submitting
a will to Almighty God. Peace acquired
by submitting a will to Almighty God. So
the best religion in Islam and all the
prophets of God, Adam, Abraham, Moses,
Jesus, Muhammad peace be upon them, all
all of them preached Islam. Islam means
peace acquired by submitting to Almighty
God. Hope that answers the question.
Okay. Thank you. So why do we follow
religion?
Why do we follow religion? Yes.
Because when we follow religion, we will
pass the examination. This world is a
test for the hereafter. Allah says in
surah mul chapter number 16 verse number
two, Allah has created death and life to
test which of you is good indeed. You go
to school. Yes. Yes. You sit for an
examination. Yes. You read the book.
Yes. If you pass, you get a degree.
Correct. Okay. So here also this is a
test for the hereafter. Almighty God is
saying he's testing the human
beings. Which of us is good indeed? So
if we follow the law of Almighty God,
the final law is the Quran. If you
follow the law, you pass the test and
you go to heaven. If you don't follow
the law, you will you will not go to
heaven. Same thing in the Bible. If you
break one jot or tit, Jesus Christ peace
be upon him said in the gospel of
Matthew chapter number five verse number
17 to 20 that I have come not to destroy
the law of the prophets. I've come not
to destroy but to
fulfill fulfilled and not one jot or
till pass away from the law until all be
fulfilled. So we have to follow the
religion so that we pass and we go to
heaven and we go to paradise. Hope that
answers the question. Is there any
difference between the religion? One
question at a time. So you can come
tomorrow. Tomorrow the full talk is on
that. You hear the talk and you can ask
the question. I already answered three
questions of you. Okay. Last question.
Is there any difference between the
religion and the only books that we read
that include the Quran and the Bible?
The sister asked the question is there
any difference between the religion and
the books we follow Quran and the Bible?
Religion means following the word of
God. So if you follow the Quran which is
the last and final word of God it's
correct. Today's Bible that we have
sister it's a
mixture. The Bible we have it has some
words of God. It had words of prophets
it has words of historian. It is even as
pornography.
Okay. Do you know
pornography? For example, if you give me
a million dollar. Yes. And you tell me
read Ezekiel
24:24. Ezekiel chapter number 24 verse
number 24 is a part of the Bible which
is
pornographic. Even if you give me a
million dollar not million shilling
million dollar I will not read it
because in Islam I cannot reach such
filth in front of the public. You
understand now? Yes. So this Bible it's
a mixture. Some things are word of God.
If it matches with the Quran we say no
problem.
We have no problem in accepting the word
of God. If it's against the Quran, we
reject it. If it's not against and not
matching, maybe right, maybe wrong. So
that's the reason I want to follow
something which is pure. For example, I
get for you pure glass of drinking
water. Will you drink it?
I get for you pure pure drinking water.
Will you drink it? Yes. Yes. Now in that
water I get a pure drink pure glass of
drinking water. Then from the gutter I
take one drop of filth and put it into
the water in front of you and stir it.
If you put one drop in a glass of water
of dirt after stirring can you see it?
No. Correct. Yes. Now once you have seen
I put the dirt then will you drink it?
No. Ah very good. Because you're
intelligent. because it's adulterated.
So now you have the Quran, you have the
Bible. Bible is pure the word of God.
Sorry, the Quran is the pure word of
God. Bible is
adulteration. So which will you follow?
Quran or the Bible?
The Bible. Bible dirt mixture.
Adulterated. Why? Now you're not
intelligent. So far you are intelligent.
Why am I not? I'm a Christian. I should
follow the Bible. No, no, no. You should
follow the word of God, not follow the
Bible. Where does the Bible say follow
the Bible?
Do you know what is the meaning of the
word Bible?
It's holy book. It's a holy book. No,
Bible come from the Greek word biblo.
You don't even know. I know more of the
Bible than you. Have you read the Bible?
Of course, I've read the Bible. What
made you read the Bible? Ah what made me
because you know when I see my friends
around me I love them. They are being
misguided. So I read the Bible to guide
them. Why you not doing a comparison
between the Bible and the Quran? Sorry.
Why you not doing the comparison between
the Bible and the Quran? Yes. That's
what I do. That's my job. Why? Why? Yes.
Very good question. Because almighty God
tells me in my Quran in surah Imran
3:64 say to the Jews and
[Music]
Christians come to common terms as
between us and you which is the first
term Allah that we worship none but one
Allah one God. So when I see I've got so
many Christian friends who have been
misguided. So I studied the Bible I
studied the Quran. I being a doctor
applied scientific test Bible failed.
There are many scientific errors. There
are many mathematical mistakes. So this
cannot be from God. So then I started
telling my friends see compared and many
of my friends accepted Islam. I love
them. I don't want them to go to hell.
You know how many hundreds I give talks
in India. many of my Hindu friends, many
of my Christian friends and here also
you saw one one person starting simple
Islam. So I love my Christian brothers
and sisters. I want them to come to the
truth and if I'm wrong, you correct me.
Correct. If I'm speaking something
wrong, you can correct
me. So my job is to get the people to
the truth.
Jesus Christ peace be upon him said,
"Seek ye is the truth and the truth
shall free you." Did he say that or not?
He did. Huh? Yes or no?
Yes. So why aren't you seeking the
truth? Mashallah, you came here. It's
good. I'm happy. I'm happy you came
here, sister. Thank you. I'm happy. So,
and I pray to Almighty God that now when
I'm talking is are you understanding
what I'm trying to say? Yes. that I want
you to worship the true
God. Who is the true God? Almighty God.
Almighty. Not human being. Yeah.
Can a person who die, can he be God? No.
Jesus Christ died on the cross.
There's no proof. Did not prove. Oh, it
says in the
It's are written but not proved. Huh?
It's written in the Bible but not
proved. It is sur. Yes. What is sur?
It's written. Oh, it's written in the
Bible. Oh, what does the church say? If
it he did not die.
He died and he rose again. He died so
cannot die and he will rise again. Okay.
Would you like to believe in a God which
can die or cannot die?
Who? I still believe in him. No. No.
Who's powerful? I believe I believe when
one falls he or she stands again. So I
believe in Jesus. What type of God?
Someone can kill God. What type of a
God? I prefer believing God who cannot
die. And then your church says God went
to hell for 3 days.
Correct. Can God go to hell for what?
For punishment. He died for the sins of
human being. Correct? Yes. Where does it
say?
Gospel of John chapter number 3 verse
number 16. He died. You read the Bible
gospel of John chapter number 3 verse
number 16. For God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son.
Whosoever believeth in him shall not die
but have everlasting life. Correct? Yes.
It's a quotation from the Bible. But the
Christian scholars of the highest
eminence in the revised standard version
of the Bible, they say the word begotten
is interpolation. It's a concoction.
It's a fabrication. They threw it out of
the Bible. So if you read the revised
standard version, the word begotten is
not there.
That means somebody's playing around
with the Bible. Correct. I still believe
in the Bible. Do you know one thing? The
Bible give equality to everybody.
Bible gives it give equal equality to
everybody. The human gender and the
female, the male and the and the female
gender. But the Quran, I've never seen
it giving equality to the women gender.
Okay. Where does it not give? Give me
one point where Quran doesn't give
equality to women. Tell me one thing.
One point.
Like like in in the
Bible we see now most mostly women women
are allowed to preach
in front of the church and they can even
spread the the
gospel. We women women are allowed to
attend church every day anytime you want
to. But in
Islamic I don't see that happening. They
go on specific periods. Who told you
women are allowed to pee? Do you know my
wife? My wife is giving a lecture now.
Oh no. All right.
Now where in the mosque? She's giving a
lecture. Yesterday in the mosque she
gave 500 ladies came. So how you saying
she cannot go? In Islam a woman can go
to the mosque. It's not compulsory. Our
beloved prophet said, "Do not prevent
the female servant of Allah from
entering the mosque in Sai Bkhari." Yes,
it is not compulsory but she can go. So
where do you get this from? From where?
Again allegations against Islam. My wife
is
preaching Pakistan. She gave a lecture
to women bigger than this audience. You
know in this tent more than that she
gave lecture to
My wife she gives lecture only to ladies
she
gives. So how can you say women cannot
preach in Islam? I've not seen that
happening in Kenya actually. Okay. So
why don't you go to my wife lecture
tomorrow? So she's giving.
Okay. Okay. Till you attend tomorrow.
Yes. Okay. Hope to see you there. Thank
you. But I pray to God that may he guide
you.